[Music]
mm big fan of your work
this is hassan from tunisia a material
science at the University of Freiburg in
Germany my question for you today is how
can it be that human beings still can't
communicate with animals I mean we have
powerful computers by now isn't it just
easy to just record a lot of data let
the computer look for pattern and play
them back and analyze the responses
imagine all the implications animals can
become relatives for us or even closer
friends egg we can even ask them what
the perspective on life is I hope you
answered my question have a nice day
hello Hasek did I pronounce your cracker
do my best I only heard it once and the
sounds not too out hostak greetings
thank you for your question can we
communicate with animals better than we
do now let me say I've spent a lot of
time with dogs and I really have a sense
of what they're thinking I certainly
have a sense of when they're happy and
when they're sad I've spent a little bit
of time with gorillas now I'm talking
about a tiny amount of time but you can
certainly tell when a gorillas happy
when a grill is an angry and you can
also tell when gorillas are
communicating with each other now this
is one of the things I wonder about all
the time is there a gradient is there an
increasing a stair-step of intelligence
of language skill between let's say a
Gibbon a bonobo a gorilla chimpanzee a
human is there a gradient of
intelligence from cow to horse to zebra
to giraffe I don't know but these
animals certainly the mammals anyway
certainly have emotions that we can
detect and interact with but I'm very
skeptical so far that animals really
ponder the universe and our place within
it and I'm very skeptical that but know
Bose or chimpanzees have developed
something like the periodic table of the
elements
however with that said if you ever saw
the movie up which is an animated movie
I think the word poignant in English
would be very descriptive it's
bittersweet but there's a fabulous
scientific premise science fiction
premise where the inventor has a collar
that enables dogs to speak English it's
fabulous and I don't know maybe they
translate it into German and you've
watched it in German but wouldn't that
be fun if you could talk to dogs in
English or English lower human language
sentences wouldn't that just be the most
fun ever but I'm skeptical just for
example when a human dies we go to all
kinds of trouble we've got funeral homes
and cemeteries and so on but when a
primate dies there is apparently a
period of mourning in the troop or the
barrel of monkeys of chimpanzees but
then they get over it much more quickly
than humans do and I wonder is that for
evolution like they have to get over in
order to go forage for food and get on
with their lives or is their memory of
it just kind of not as intense as humans
because they don't have this language
that we a language that reinforces this
person's memory and the interactions you
have with this your fellow primate I
wonder this so the answer your question
I am absolutely not sure but intuitively
it seems like this gradient of
intelligence would limit the amount that
we could talk with animals now by the
way I don't know if you've ever been
into Aquaman he can talk to fish he
talks to fish Tarzan king of the jungle
talks to all his animal guys people
animal friends they're not people and so
that is certainly something that humans
have thought about for centuries or
those myths wouldn't exist has it one
more
about using computers to communicate
with animals keep in mind that the
computers have to be programmed somebody
would have to at least early here in the
21st century computers are not
self-organizing enough to decide to make
a program to communicate with animals
but in the ornithology community birds
bird people who study birds they work
really hard to understand bird calls
they record them reproduce them try to
communicate with birds certainly people
try to imitate whale sounds and marine
mammal sounds but I don't think it's to
the point where anybody's taking a
meeting with them and talking about the
fundamental theorem of calculus or the
rocket equation or how to raise crops
underwater or whatever it is so I'm
interested in this gradient of
intelligence and it'll be up to you to
write the computer program that enables
this idea of yours the answer is
definitely maybe
[Music]